sure it's easy to understand why someone
would regret shooting a superhero flick
right with cheesy lines and marketing
plugs but despising your part in one of
the most beloved Blockbusters of the 9s
you won't believe some of the movies
these actors regret filming he may be
one of Hollywood's biggest action heroes
but Sylvester Stallone has had his
failures too from the much maligned
Judge Dread to the awkward 80s Dolly
Parton drama rhinestone he probably
regrets a great many films in his career
but there's one 90s flop that stands
head and shoulders of Above the Rest the
1992 action comedy stop or my mom will
shoot stop or my mom will shoot is best
known for being the film Stallone was
tricked into making by none other than
action rival Arnold Schwarzenegger who
pretended to be after the role himself
he told The Hollywood Reporter I had
heard Schwarzenegger was going to do
that movie and I said I'm going to beat
him to it I think he set me up instantly
regretting it he was confused by the
rest of the film's casting particularly
Golden Girl star Estelle Getty he
recalled it was supposed to be like
Throw Mama From from the train with the
mom as this really nasty piece of work
instead you hire the nicest woman in
Hollywood Estelle Getty who you wish was
your mother in the years since Stallone
has made his hatred of the film known
telling GQ in 2017 if you ever want
someone to confess to murder just make
him or her sit through that film they
will confess to anything after 15
minutes the moment you hear the name
George Clooney on a list of regrettable
movies you probably already know which
movie is being lamented it's one of the
most infamous comic book adaptations
ever of film so bad it killed a
franchise and nearly destroyed multiple
careers released in 1997 and directed by
Joel Schumacher Batman and Robin was the
fourth film in the series and Clooney's
first big Blockbuster project after
starring in the hit medical drama ER
needless to say it was also a notorious
flop for a variety of reasons including
a Shameless American Express
[Applause]
plug never leave the cave without it
instead of making Clooney a sought after
Action Hero he had to spend years a
apologizing for it Clooney said in an
appearance on The Graham Norton Show in
2015 that he always apologizes for his
involvement in the film but you know I
thought at the time this was going to be
a very good career move um it
wasn't and he hasn't sto trashing the
film in 2020 in an interview with Howard
Stern he went further into just how
awful the flick really is the star
remarked AKA goldsman who's won the
Oscar for writing since then he wrote
the screenplay and it's a terrible
screenplay he'll tell you Joel schacher
who just passed away directed it and
he'd say yeah it didn't work but Clooney
didn't just lay the blame at the feet of
others he readily admits to his own
failure playing Bruce Wayne he conceded
and the truth of the matter is I was bad
in it we all sort of go yeah we all we
all whiffed on that one star of
countless big screen Classics Tom Hanks
counts six Academy Award nominations to
his name including two wins he also has
seven prime time Emmy Awards as a
producer on such favorites as Band of
Brothers and Olive kid yet even with all
his success Hanks still has a movie that
he finds hard to stomach years later
directed by Brian dealma and co-starring
Bruce Willis Melanie Griffith and Morgan
Freeman the bonfire of the vanities
makes Hanks cringe to this day a black
comedy based on the celebrated 1987
novel by Tom Wolf the film sees Hanks
play Sherman McCoy a Wall Street Power
Player husband and father whose wealth
isn't quite what it seems as his
finances get stretched to their limits
he accidentally kills a bystander with
his car while out with his mistress when
this is discovered by a local attorney
it leads to a firestorm it's a story
with a lot to say on racism class
inequality and the excess of the80s but
even with all of its high-minded themes
it just isn't very good he told Oprah
Winfrey in a 2001 interview in O it's
one of the crappiest movies ever made
and Hanks wasn't alone in this opinion
the film was a box office bomb that was
met with derision from critics making
many worst of the 9s lists getting his
start on TV in The Fresh Prince of bell
air Will Smith shot to big screen
stardom in the 9s with a string of
blockbuster hits he had a 4-year run of
success that's hard to top with bad boys
in 1995 Independence Day in 1996 Men In
Black in 1997 and the criminally
underrated political thriller Enemy of
the State in 1998 unfortunately his luck
just couldn't hold and in 1999 he made
perhaps the worst film of his career he
said many times he wishes he'd never
made it he told people in 2021 Wild Wild
West is a thorn in my side to see myself
in chaps I don't like it why did he do
the movie at all Smith says it was his
own fault for getting carried away by
that incredible run of Blockbusters
Smith said in an interview with GQ in
2016 I had so much success that I
started to taste Global blood and my
focus shifted from my Artistry to
winning I found myself promoting
something because I wanted to win versus
promoting something because I believed
in it to make matters worse wild wild
west is the movie Smith made after
turning down the role of Neo in The
Matrix a game-changing bad decision he
still laments to this day by 1995 whoopy
Goldberg had already long established
herself as one of the most talented
actresses in Hollywood she received an
Academy Award nomination in 1986 for her
leading role in The Color Purple and
took home the trophy for best supporting
actress in 1991 for ghost she' featured
in a recurring role on the acclaimed
Sci-Fi series Star Trek the Next
Generation appeared in a pair of Sister
Act movies and was coming off her role
as shenzi in The Lion King that's when
she made easily the worst movie in her
career and she knew she would regret it
the moment she stepped before the camera
it's a cop we got to make him look like
a real car I'm too sexy for my clothes
that's because Goldberg's part in
Theodore Rex wasn't actually one that
she wanted to perform she'd even gone so
far as to try to back out of the project
but was forced to follow through she's
never been shy about expressing her
disdain for the movie since either
during her days as a co-host on the
daytime talk show The View she once said
the film makes no sense to anyone
despite the fact that it has its fans
she wishes it could be erased from
existence when it comes to superhero
movies there may be no role more coveted
than Batman but it wasn't always that
way played by Adam West in the 1966
television series and an accompanying
theatrical release it wasn't until
Michael Keaton put on the cape and Cal
for Tim Burton's 1989 Batman that all of
Hollywood took notice so when Keaton
stepped away after a pair of films the
role became a sought-after one Vel
Kilmer was as excited as you would
imagine to get behind the wheel of the
Batmobile for 1995's Batman Forever but
years before Clooney regretted its
sequel Kilmer ended up having a
miserable experience playing Batman
unfortunately along with Katon director
Tim Burton exited the threequel incoming
Helmer Joel schacher brought with him a
very different take on the character
that's when Kilmer's enthusiasm faded he
said in his 2021 documentary whatever
Boyhood excitement I had was crushed by
the reality of the bat suit yes every
boy wants to be Batman they actually
want to be him not necessarily play him
in a movie but that's what Kilmer was
doing and the critical drubbing the
movie received further killed his
interest in continuing to play the
character 2 years later Kilmer quit the
series unwilling to debase himself
further with another sequel It's hard to
imagine an actor regretting not just the
biggest role in their career but a film
that currently sits among the highest
grossing ever made now imagine that film
is also one of the most beloved films in
the history of Cinema with fans of all
ages passionate about its action
adventure and romance what could there
be to regret well there's no need to
imagine because the movie is James
Cameron's Titanic and its star Kate
Winslet who isn't so thrilled that
people are still re-watching it year
after year not because the movie is bad
but because she can't stand her own
performance in it stay
back don't come any closer Winslet said
during press interviews for the film's
3D re-release in 2012 it's awful it
sounds terribly self-indulgent but
actors do tend to be very self-critical
I have a hard time watching any of my
performances but watching Titanic I was
just like oh God I want to do that again
it's a performance and film that she can
barely sit through despite its lofty
reputation and millions of adoring fans
she mentioned every single scene I'm
like really really you did it like that
oh my God still she has some consolation
Winslet was nominated for an Academy
Award for her role as Rose though she
might be glad she lost out to Helen Hunt
to avoid further attention for it Sandra
Bullock became one of Hollywood's
biggest Rising starlets after appearing
opposite Sylvester Stallone in the 1993
action movie Demolition Man a year later
she started with Keo Reeves in the
Blockbuster classic speed but when a
sequel was greenlet Reeves chose not to
return this gave bulock the rare chance
to take a leading role in her very own
action movie with Jason Patrick as her
co-star unfortunately when all was said
and done the movie was a huge flop
barely making back its own budget and in
the years since the actress has admitted
just how much she wishes it had never
happened in 2022 she was asked by two
Fab if there was any movie in her career
that she initially didn't like but that
perhaps she'd learned to appreciate
because of its fan following she said I
have one there no one came around to and
I'm still embarrassed I was in it's
called speed two admitting that the plot
of a slow-moving boat never really made
a lick of sense to begin with bulock
revealed that the entire project was a
shameful Cinema sinim from top to bottom
after the interviewer claimed they
enjoyed the film she said that's one
that I wished I hadn't done
and no fans came
around that I know except for you Bruce
Willis made a name for himself on the
small screen as detective David Addison
in Moonlighting before making the leap
to the movies when he did he became an
instant star thanks to 1988's diart
where he played Grizzle cop John mlan he
struggled to recapture that film's
success though in disappointments like
Hudson Hawk and Billy Bathgate perhaps
trying to go back to the kind of role
that made him a movie star he became a
cop in 1993's Striking dis
Willis plays a homicide detective named
Tom Hardy but it isn't quite the same
role as John mlan for one thing Hardy is
relegated to the role of river Rescue
Squad far from the city-based excitement
of Die Hard the movie wasn't a hit and
was mercilessly maligned by critics when
looking back on his career in a chat
with Ain't It Cool News Willis threw the
film under the bus calling it a dog for
which he hangs his head in shame
thankfully it's a movie that most
audiences have seemed to forget about
being happier to focus on his winning
entries the 1994 romantic comedy I love
trouble had everything going for it
starting with its star studded cast led
by Julia Roberts and Nick Noti it
boasted a pair of big names who
producers dreamed would become a classic
Hollywood couple allaha heurn and Tracy
unfortunately the result was a total dud
with the two leads having fewer Sparks
than a dead Zippo lighter it completely
bombed at the box office but that's not
the only reason why Julia Roberts
regrets the film famously Roberts and
Noti did not get along at all on the set
of the film according to contemporary
accounts in the Los Angeles Times the
two feuded constantly with Roberts more
than a little annoyed by his male
chauvinism the fact that he reportedly
openly insulted her on set didn't help
rumors flew that things got so bad that
they refused to even be near each other
often filming their scenes separately
with standin though these details were
never commented on by either of them
Roberts did openly call her co-star
completely disgusting in that Los
Angeles Times interview and Niti has
since responded with equal contempt for
her suffice it to say the production was
an extremely unpleasant one that Roberts
doesn't even like to talk about these
days in 1988 Bob Hoskins starred in one
of the first and still best movies to
combine live action and animation when
he played Eddie Valiant in Who Framed
Roger rabbits but 5 years later he tried
to duplicate that success in another
family film and wound up leading a movie
so famously awful it single-handedly
destroyed an entire genre later in life
Hoskins wasn't shy about discussing just
how much he regretted ever starring in
the 1993 video game adaptation of Super
Mario Brothers he said in a wide-
ranging interview with the guardian in
2007 the worst thing I ever did Super
Mario Brothers it was a nightmare the
whole experience was a
[Applause]
nightmare he continued his explo of
Laden rant against the film going on to
say it had a husband and wife team
directing whose arrogance had been
mistaken for talent after so many weeks
their own agent told them to get off the
set
nightmare idiots ultimately the film
wound up as poorly received by audiences
and critics as it was by Hoskins it gave
the emerging genre of video game
adaptations a bad name and pretty much
everyone involved probably wishes it
never happened I you should play King
Leia since she Rose to Fame in the late
'70s as Lorie stroe in John Carpenter's
Halloween Jam Lee Curtis has made scores
of iconic films but she's made almost as
many bad ones too in fact Curtis has
more than one film that she's expressed
regret over and one of them was a sequel
to that John Carpenter original we're
talking about Halloween H2O 20 years
later after sitting out four Halloween
sequels she agreed to return in 1998 but
quickly realized she'd made a mistake
Curtis told ew to this day I regret that
I didn't say to everyone if Deborah
Hill's not the one producing this movie
I'm not doing it but what ended up
happening was she wasn't part of it JN
wasn't part of it and I was still part
of it and it was a machine going down
the road so far we've covered for a
variety of reasons actors regret even
their biggest films but superstar Mark
Wahlberg has a unique one and it
involves his faith a devout Catholic
there are movies from his early days in
Hollywood that he looks back on with
serious misgivings and chief among them
is the 1997 comedy drama Boogie Knights
it puts the future a-lister into the
role of an adult film star and while
it's always been met with Stella reviews
and has a fervent fan following it's not
something that Wahlberg is proud of
first came comments at a religious
Summit in 2017 where the actor called
out his role as Diggler as something he
regrets he told the audience I just
always hope that God is a movie fan and
also forgiving because I've made some
poor choices in my past Boogie kns is up
there at the top of the list quickly
those comments swept the web and Walberg
had to explain further telling people
magazine that the role was one that the
Lord probably wasn't understanding of
given its extremely adult connotations
Walberg wasn't the only one to regret
the film though co-star Bert Reynolds
reportedly hated the film so much that
he fired his agent over it we can all
sympathize with an actor who regrets a
bad movie but when it comes to ahed best
things get downright heartbreaking a
theater performer whose career already
included the Broadway smash stomp he was
plucked from the stage to play the first
fully digital main character in the Star
Wars universe but because he play jar
jar Banks best became the target of fan
outrage when the first prequel film
irked longtime die hards uh you're
somebody be saying that the harassment
best received turned his life upside
down best said on Twitter I faced a
media backlash that still affects my
career today most upsettingly the actor
admits that things got so bad he
seriously considered suicide posting a
photo of the New York Harbor best shared
his story with his followers this was
the place I almost ended my life it's
still hard to talk about thankfully best
was able to recover emotionally but not
without years of turmoil he shared with
wired in 2017 there were a lot of Tears
there was a lot of pain it's fair to
wonder if he wouldn't have been better
off without the role entirely still he
made his return to the franchise in a
2023 episode of the
Mandalorian Star Trek has a strong track
record when it comes to guest stars
going all the way back to the original
series when Joan Collins made an
appearance in city on the edge of
forever the movies kept that tradition
with Ricardo montabon and Christopher
Lloyd in the second and third films
cinematic takes on Star Trek the Next
Generation followed suit it was
Clockwork Orange star Malcolm McDow who
filled the role of celebrity guest in
1994's Star Trek generations but from
the sound of it he wasn't a happy camper
when he made the moveie movie according
to McDow Star Trek was stale and boring
when he appeared in it and the cast was
even worse reported by Trek movie he
said I did them a favor Patrick Stewart
spouting off for another 40 minutes
Jesus if you find that exciting hey go
watch paint dry the film which was met
with tepid reviews was a modest success
but clearly isn't one that McDow looks
back on with any amount of fondness Brad
Pit was just as huge in the '90s as he
is today starring in Classics like seven
Interview with the Vampire and Fight
Club
I want you to hit me as hard as you can
he's not without his Clunkers though and
the worst of them all might be an entry
from 1997 that the star himself seems to
regret not just because the devil's own
was downright awful but because its
production was plagued with problems
from start to finish problems that
famously included frequent clashes with
co-star Harrison Ford all of those
issues can probably be traced to the
fact that the project got greenlit
without any plan pit told Newsweek we
had no script well we we had a great
script but it got tossed for various
reasons to have to make something up as
you go along it was the most
irresponsible bit of film making if you
can even call it that that I've ever
seen he continued his rant I couldn't
believe it I don't know why anyone would
want to continue making that movie we
had nothing at one point pit became so
frustrated that he asked to get out of
the movie but the studio wasn't budging
and demanded a massive multi-million
doll payout from their star if he walked
in the end the movie got made and while
it paired two of Hollywood's biggest
names it flopped in theater
co-founder of the British comedy troop
Monty Python Michael Palin starred in
one of the freshest comedies of the80s A
Fish Called Wanda an uously funny film
co-starring Kevin kleene Jamie Lee
Curtis and his python cohort John C who
also co-wrote and co-directed it it won
Klein an Academy Award for best actor
and remains beloved decades later though
they never made a sequel the entire cast
reunited for a spiritual successor
Fierce creatures in 1997 but if you ask
Palin it was a huge mistake interviewed
by the telegraph decades later Palin
lamented the entire process of making
the film he described his frustration at
constant rewrites with C even reducing
his part Midway through filming Palin
remarked that it took 4 months of my
life to film is on the other hand barely
believable from the amount of time on
screen even when filming first wrapped
The Experience wasn't over not long
before its planned release Palin was
told that early test screenings went
poorly and a wealth of re-shoot were
required with a newly recruited
screenwriter C overhaul the script yet
again Palin seemed proud of the final
product until even more test screenings
in New York forced the whole thing to be
cut down Palin added after all these
years of time energy money and hard
graft FC looks likely to be a 90-minute
quickie its shape and content decided
eventually by 20 people in Long Island
no Yan McGregor doesn't regret Star Wars
Episode 1 The Phantom Menace the way his
co-star Amed best does after all he was
able to Parlay the part into his own
Obi-Wan Centric series on Disney plus
some 20 years later instead the Scottish
actor who came to fame thanks to Indie
hit train spotting looks back with a
sense of disgust on the period drama
Emma based on the classic novel by Jane
Austin asked which work in his career
he'd consider his worst McGregor was
quick to answer he said in 2003 in a
piece for the guardian workwise my
character Frank Churchill on Emma I made
the decision to do that film because I
thought I should be seen to be doing
something different from train spotting
he continued to lament his role my
decision- making was wrong it's a good
fil Emma but I'm just not very good in
it I'm not helped because I'm also
wearing the world's worst wig that said
while he may regret his performance and
the film McGregor said he used it as a
valuable learning experience and earned
a newfound understanding of how best to
pick his Parts presumably he now chooses
projects that offer him a better head of
hair Austrian bodybuilder turned actor
turned politician Arnold Schwarzenegger
has a number of films in his catalog he
might winse at including his very first
comedy Hercules in New York but that's
not the one he regrets as as a matter of
fact the one he seems to have the most
serious qualms about is one that remains
a cult favorite the 1993 fantasy action
comedy Last Action Hero help me get me
out of here my God this man's not dead a
bomb in theaters the film wasn't liked
by critics and was seen by audiences as
a huge step down from his previous
effort Terminator 2 Judgment Day this
reaction had the star rethinking his
entire career he said in his Netflix
documentary Arnold when Last Action Hero
came out I reached my Peak after
Terminator 2 having the most successful
movie of the year worldwide so when the
reviews for the film rolled out I cannot
tell you how upset that I was it hurts
you it hurts your feelings it's
embarrassing glum over the negative
response Arnold withdrew completely he
said I didn't want to see anyone for a
week to cope he relied on support from
his family and friends including
frequent collaborator James Cameron
Cameron said in the series he took it as
a deep blow to his brand I think it
really shook him thanks to that support
Arnold was able to overcome his regrets
and team back up with Cameron for his
comeback a year later in True Lies
British actor Hugh Grant has made plenty
of mistakes in his career when it comes
to his movies though he definitely knows
which one he regrets most 9 months but
it's not for any of the usual reasons
you'd expect despite it being one of the
worst movies in his filmography 9 months
isn't a movie he wishes he hadn't done
because it was bad but because of who
financed it controversial billionaire
Tycoon rert Murdoch he told
Entertainment Weekly it would certainly
stick in my craw to work for Fox I did
make 9 months for them 16 years ago but
I was naive then I didn't even know who
owned the studio the comments came in
response to a phone hacking Scandal that
rocked Britain where the paper news of
the world was caught up in allegations
that it had tapped the phones of a
number of celebrities granted helped
catch them in the act by recording a
conversation with one of their reporters
and went on record about how disgusted
he was by the papers owner Murdoch who
also owned 20th Century Fox if you or
anyone you know is having suicidal
thoughts please call the national SU
side prevention Lifeline by dialing 988
or by calling 1 1800273 Talk 800
2738255
[Music]